Paris, jeudi 25 juillet 2019.
La canicule est sur le point
de s'intensifier,
raison pour laquelle
la vigilance a encore été étendue.
Il est 15 h 20, le mercure affiche 42,4 degrés
à l'ombre dans les rues de la capitale.
Une température jamais atteinte,
pulvérisant le record historique de 1947.
La canicule de 2019 a été exceptionnelle
par son intensité en France.
C'est inquiétant parce que 42 degrés
à Paris, c'est encore une vraie question,
entre la température ressentie
et la température réelle.
Le manque d'air, surtout !
Je vais rentrer chez moi, fermer
les fenêtres et ne plus sortir.
On n'est pas habitué à ces températures-là.
Surtout dans les grandes villes,
on parle d'îlots de chaleur.
C'est lié au bitume, lié au fait
que les immeubles sont très collés.
Donc comment on vit
quand on subit une canicule ?
On recherche des points d'eau,
on va vers des fontaines.
Elle n'arrive plus
à boire de l'eau ?
Écoutez, je vous envoie une ambulance.
Elle a perdu connaissance ou pas madame ?
On a eu un été où les gens ont compris
ce qu'était le changement climatique.
Le français a compris parce que ça ne se passe
plus à l'autre bout de la planète,
parce que ce n'est plus le Groenland
ou le Canada qui va être directement concerné.
Ou bien, on ne va plus parler uniquement
des ours, on va parler du Parisien qui a chaud,
on va parler du Gardois
qui va vivre avec 46 degrés.
Donc c'est vraiment
un basculement dans les mentalités.
Et d'un coup, on se dit :
"Mais c'est vrai !
Il faut qu'on fasse quelque chose !"
On voit très bien qu'il faut s'adapter
obligatoirement parce que ça va s'accélérer.
En effet, cette canicule
que nous pensions exceptionnelle,
pourrait bien faire partie
demain de notre quotidien.
On va sans doute subir de plus
en plus de canicules aussi sévères.
Elle pourrait intervenir
tous les ans en France.
Et surtout de durer plus longtemps.
Là, on a eu des pointes de température.
Bon, ça a été dur pendant 4-5 jours,
après, c'est retombé.
Si ça dure 15 jours,
3 semaines, un mois...
Des canicules beaucoup plus longues,
qui pourraient donc avoir
des répercussions dramatiques sur notre santé.
L'être humain doit avoir une température constante
à 37 degrés, ce qu'on appelle l'homéostasie.
Avec une température extérieure
extrêmement importante,
on a tendance à avoir une température
qui a du mal à se réguler.
Et si ça dure la nuit, on n'a pas de moyen
de recharger, de diminuer cette température.
Et donc du coup, ces 37 degrés sont
de plus en plus difficiles à maintenir.
Subir des canicules, ce n'est pas bon
pour la santé, ni le corps.
Donc si on le subit régulièrement, il y aura
des conséquences sanitaires, c'est sûr en France.
Le nombre de décès
pourrait être multiplié par 30 ou 40,
dépasser les 100 000
en plus chaque année,
et la quasi-totalité
de ces décès serait lié aux canicules.
Vous pouvez vous mettre nu !
Vous y passerez quand même !
Non seulement les canicules
seront plus récurrentes, plus longues,
mais elles seront aussi
beaucoup plus chaudes.
Car si en 100 ans, la température
sur Terre a augmenté d'un degré,
elle pourrait bien grimper de manière
fulgurante dans les prochaines années.
Ce n'est pas linéaire du tout, où petit à petit
on va gagner 1/10 degré tous les 10 ans.
Non, ça s'accélère en plus !
Si on continue à agir comme on agit,
si on continue à émettre
autant de gaz à effet de serre.
D'ici à la fin du siècle, la température
pourrait monter de 6 à 7 degrés,
ce qui est énorme !
Si on va à 7-8 degrés, je ne dirai plus
que c'est plus un changement climatique,
C'est un cataclysme !
C'est ça qu'il faut que j'en réalise.
On va voir le climat de l'Afrique
qui va remonter jusqu'aux latitudes Nord.
Là, c'est un sacré bouleversement.
Il va peut-être falloir se mettre à vivre en
mode espagnol avec plus de phases de siestes.
Je bosse beaucoup moins,
on travaille très tôt le matin.
Peut-être manger plus tard, peut-être vivre
plus tard le soir et décaler notre journée.
Ce sont des vraies questions
qu'on doit se poser et que les sociétés,
vont être amenées à vivre au quotidien
et à se poser de plus en plus.
Dans les années à venir, nous serons
donc forcés de trouver des solutions,
contre la chaleur et ce,
pour protéger notre santé.